sorry did you buy back in bad nerve
another table not very scientific Murph
what's going on nerve I think these are
not a dabbler
no what Moore's kind of your kids doing
especially Murph I'll be back in a
couple hours murder
I don't think so Murphy his handle he's
here to talk about Murph Murph is a
great kid Murph got into a fistfight
with several four classmates Murph is
feeling a little tired you want to talk
science it's not Morse Murph it's binary
primary tumor I asked move to say hi
Murph was there this inner Owen Murph
have you eaten in luck that you like
some monster play you have to talk to me
American it's right for me Murph they
chose me come on Murph don't make me
leave like this Murph hello Murph Murph
is a bright spark it only has to work
once No are you calling my life's work
nonsense I'm an old man if we put it
Murph you tried your best Murph we don't
have time for this come on Murph the
fires out come on
he's got it Oh Murphy we're for telling
Matt if you state Murphy make him stay
Murph he'll let me leave Murph don't let
me leave Murph we'll find a way
tell me my connection with Murph me we
got Tom's scores back Tom's scoring grab
the spare time Tom Tom Tom I'm dropping
Tom stead and raise you to be this dumb
Tom Tom will do just fine
Tom we'll be all right but you got to
make things right with Murph I will
the Lannisters are getting ready for a
wedding of their own
King Joffrey and everyone's favorite
gold digger Margaery Tyrell let's face
it if it's got a crown she's down